c'est la suède qui préside depuis ce
matin l'union européenne pour la
première fois depuis son entrée dans
cette union en 1995 mais c'est la grèce
qui fait l'événement
la grèce qui devient le douzième membres
de la zone euro un an avant l'arrivée
pratique de la monnaie européenne la
grèce connaît actuellement une bonne
croissance économique
emilie lensois un avis mme picard ont
enquêté auprès des acteurs de cette
économie grecque qui semble renaître
autre nouveauté réussi la grèce est
enfin dans le groupe nous sommes dans le
plus grand magasin de cosmétique datait
pas encore de double étiquetage mais est
la caisse
les prix sont en nouveau une monnaie
malgré tout encore un peu virtuel
je crois que nous rend ça fait autour
d'eux
300 drachme mais je ne suis pas très sûr
340 drac le 75 très exactement deux ans
après l'avènement de l'euro la grèce
rejoint les onze autres membres du club
une perspective de prospérité pour les
entreprises de façon à faciliter le
commerce pour toutes les entreprises et
pas seulement pour la nôtre la monnaie
unique va favoriser nos échanges avec le
reste de l'europe
mais l'abandon du drachme l'une des plus
vieilles monnaies européennes est un
déchirement pour certains mental
d'autant plus difficile à accepter que
pour entrer dans le vent la population
grecque a dû faire de gros sacrifices
réduire l'inflation maîtriser les
dépenses publiques
les grecs ont connu une période
d'austérité le gouvernement a dû faire
beaucoup d'efforts pour s'adapter à
l'euro par exemple on a augmenté les
impôts c'était très lourd pour tout le
monde y compris pour moi personnellement
l'un des artisans de l'euro c'est lui
pour ce conseiller du ministre des
finances les réforme était indispensable
la preuve elles commencent à porter
leurs fruits avec la croissance la plus
forte d'europe
notre défi c'est maintenant de parvenir
à 5 % de croissance par an pour cela on
va continuer à privatiser et à réformer
longtemps considéré comme le mauvais
élève la lanterne rouge de l'europe la
grèce a accompli des progrès
spectaculaires mais ces progrès ont un
prix celui d'un plan d'austérité qui a
duré deux ans alors maintenant en
entrant dans l'euro les grecs attendent
d'être récompensés pour leur sacrifice